I think this drive holds the answers to
a lot of
a lot of wife went out of claim what
happened to George why Johnson Lawrence
were killed they were
yeah they were murdered
the things you don't know in Silo's
eighth episode we learned the rest of
the story of what happened to Juliet's
mother Hannah Jules has spent the last
20 years angry at and separated from her
father because she didn't know the truth
about what was really going on you come
to realize where her ill feelings for
her father came from through a series of
flashbacks after her brother's death her
father dealt with the loss by
withdrawing and spending too much time
at work the grief put her mother on a
dangerous path searching for answers and
she stopped caring about what lines she
had to cross to get them because they're
unaware of the cameras that spy on
everything the citizens of the silos do
her mother was led to believe that her
husband must have outed her to judicial
for building a magnifier this lack of
information led to her suicide and Jules
running away to Mechanical by this point
in the first season it's hard not to see
the parallels between what happened to
Hannah what will happened to Allison
years later and what is currently
happening to Jules as much as Dr Pete
Nichols hoped that leaving his daughter
and mechanical might lead her in another
Direction one that was concerned with
fixing things in the real world that
were right in front of her rather than
chasing after answers it's clear to both
of them by the time she tells him about
the cameras and they reconcile that
she's on the same path as her mother was
20 years ago this is a huge Revelation
for the character and for the way we
understand how she fits into the larger
picture and it's not even the biggest
reveal in the episode it becomes a full
circle moment when we find adult Jewels
back on the farming level where she
learns that Sims has been answering to
Bernard and I.T the whole time he lays
out the opposing point of view here and
underlines what people like Jules are up
against when they go looking for the
truth he says throughout our entire
existence problems have Arisen that must
be taken care of the need of of the many
require the sacrifices of the few this
is about survival and that hard drive
threatens the lives of everyone in this
Silo and you were the greatest threat to
our home in 140 years well you were in
that perfect line delivery from Tim
Robbins sets things up for the final two
episodes of the season so how did we get
here the last episode ended with the
Raiders closing in on Jules who had just
been named the last flame keeper by
Gloria of course she got out in time and
was able to hide behind a desk in the
nursery where she knows there are no
cameras to give away her location Sims
goes looking for her and we learn that
he has a history with Gloria she
remembers she helped him and his wife
conceive they were having issues she
gave them some folic acid and they were
able to have their son while he seems
legitimately thankful for that he
doesn't have a problem with threatening
to leave her in the medical ward
unmedicated for the rest of her life
that turns out to be enough she gives
him the information he's after and when
he calls in the nurse he tells her to
give her the good stuff for every dose
from now on and he Thanks Gloria the
only pushback she offers is asking if he
really thinks that they'll win and he
responds to that by saying that they
have to elsewhere Jules tries to hook up
the hard drive to one of the computers
and can't get in Billings calls her and
tells her that she needs to get back to
the office and when she gets there she
finds judicial tossing the place this is
all expertly cut with those flashbacks
to her childhood which does a good job
of showing how these cycles of control
persist over the years Hannah didn't
want other families to have that same
feeling of loss that she experienced
Juliet can't bring herself to believe
that George killed himself and these
things make them a threat to the order
that relies on strict control of
information as Sheriff Jules does have
some power though Through The Pact and
Billings explains how they can use that
against judicial and their illegal
search they go to sims's office where
he's berating his guy for bringing back
useless office supplies he tries to pass
off the blame for the search to Meadows
which Jules no longer believes after
going to see her and then she informs
them that they're there to arrest him
with Billings there to back her up with
his knowledge of The Pact which earns
him some rising from Sims after they
take him away in cuffs Jewels searches
his office and in the back of one of his
drawers she finds a pile of hidden
folders where we see Shirley's name
Walker and her mother and when she looks
inside her mother's file she sees a
person of interest surveillance report
and if you look closely you see that
it's talking about activities related to
relics a magnifying device you see that
she is a surgeon which I guess isn't
that big of a surprise since she was
operating on the rabbit but I believe in
the book she was a nurse so that's a
little bit of a change she turns the
page to see something that we don't that
literally makes her raise her eyebrows
and then she goes to see her father they
have the conversation about what really
happened with her mother after her
brother died this is where they
reconcile and she lets him know about
the cameras and she decides to go visit
Walker to see if she can get into the
hard drive when she hits the staircase
she realizes judicial has set up
checkpoints where they would look
through her bag so she has to come up
with a different plan we see Sims in the
holding cell testing out the guard
seeing what he can get away with he
doesn't seem to be all that worried
about being locked up he even has to use
a radio but the deputy draws the line
there even though he asks if that's all
right at the end of telling him no it's
a pretty good example of how people
relate to judicial even people who are
in prominent positions like deputies and
I guess I should mention that this
episode sort of cleared up a little bit
more about how things work in the last
episode I wasn't hundred percent sure
where the Raiders came from but here we
see that they are an integrated part of
judicial I don't know what that means as
far as them being related to the people
behind the door in janitorial like how
many people in judicial know what's
going on there I think it's probably a
small amount but the way that he says
don't worry about it I won't hold it
against you here when he's talking to
this Deputy really reinforces the idea
that he's not all that worried about
what Jules is doing we also see Billings
return home and see that his hand locks
up when he's trying to carry the plates
to the dinner table his wife is
concerned she thinks the stress is
making the syndrome worse he explains
that Jules put him in a position where
he had to choose between her and Sims
which from her point of view isn't even
the choice and she mentions that people
around The Silo are all saying that
she's laying the groundwork for another
Rebellion down a mechanical we see that
Walker does get the message from Pete
but then we we see the clock and realize
that Juliet's already over an hour late
we see Walker go to her door and she
looks outside calling out to anyone that
will help her and briefly when she
doesn't get an answer it looks like
she's about to face her agoraphobia but
then surely appears at the last minute
so that she doesn't have to step outside
up top we see that Lucas is in the
cafeteria again and he gets a message
from a porter that says might have
answers to W and more talk now at 6 13.
we get a quick flashback here that
reminds us that the W is a reference to
the conversation he had with Jules about
the constellation Cassiopeia that tells
him this message is from her so he heads
to her apartment when he gets there the
mirror is covered and she turns on the
water and asks him about the hard drive
he explains that sisop is for like the
head of I.T but that she would be able
to access it in her office which doesn't
help help her because she can't go there
because of that she asked him to help
her get around it and she tells him that
she thinks the drive holds the answers
to a lot of questions he's reluctant
he's a good citizen after all and she
just starts unloading all of this
information on him he can't really catch
up he's not really feeling it and he's
also not feeling that she dropped
George's name in there she pressures him
saying that he's there every night
wondering what's out there and he
counters that the rules apply to
everyone in desperation she smashes her
mirror so that she can pull out the
camera and show it to him he's obviously
quite surprised he says these are in our
homes and she says they're everywhere
and adds if we don't figure out the
truth no one else will so please help me
there is a ticking clock here she knows
that Raiders are on their way so when he
falters again she just runs off he goes
out the other way and he sees judicial
arrive to start pounding on her door
Jules attempts to skip the checkpoint
and gets held up and that's when Bernard
appears to help her get through she
starts to tell him that Meadows isn't
the one who's trying to take over it's
actually Sims and he tells her they
can't speak there so they go to the farm
and while he's asking her what it is
that they're looking for he makes the
mistake and mentions the hard drive and
then you see Sims come up behind her
then it happens Bernard says did you say
you want to go outside and very quickly
Sims is there to back him up SIMs checks
her bag and recovers the hard drive and
reminds her that he told her she would
regret arresting him in the down deep
Shirley tells Walker the news that Jules
asked to go outside which she doesn't
believe since she was on her way to meet
her there Shirley says something about
Knox saying that they would punish them
for the Rebellion but she never believed
it and then she asked Walker what
happens next on their way up the stairs
Jules tries to get Billings to help her
saying that she never said she wanted to
go outside he tells her that she can
request a hearing and then she points
out the obvious that if she did that it
would be with judicial which is run by
Sims and that sets him off to the point
where he punches her in the stomach
after that she notices billing's hand
shaking because of the syndrome and she
sees that as an opportunity and she
breaks free she grabs the bag with the
hard drive off The Sims as she pushes
past him and then she jumps over the
railing as it cuts to Black I suppose
this is a cliffhanger in a sense it's
not really a question of whether she'll
survive but more what will she do if she
gets away everything that we've been
seeing is that these people that are
behind the door in janitorial have
pretty tight control over everything
Bernard and I.T are involved Meadows
doesn't really have any power but she's
willing to put her name on anything that
they want and if this episode did
anything it showed that the position of
sheriff and the sheriff's office in
general doesn't have any real power it's
just a position that someone holds while
the real people who are in control run
everything from behind the scenes that
said this was a fantastic episode as
I've mentioned several times in my
coverage what I was hoping the TV show
would do in this process of adaptation
was flush out the characters more after
all that's what serialized TV is made
for I think they pulled that off with
Jules and with the aid of some powerful
performances you really feel that when
she tells her father she knows she was
wrong to blame him for all those years
this is an emotional moment that stands
on its own but it also reinforces the
ideas that they're playing with as they
present us with these Mysteries that we
try to work our way through this episode
was the first one that Adam Bernstein
directed his is the name I know because
he directed two of my favorite Breaking
Bad episodes season three's no half
measure years and season Four's box
cutter I think the direction has been
consistently good throughout this first
season but because it's a recognizable
name I paid attention to the details a
little more than usual and I just have
to say they do a tremendous job of
making The Silo feel real the way I
understand it the set is basically three
floors of the staircase that they build
out with a few of the levels built in
the background when they needed to look
like different levels they dropped blue
screens all around and then add that
other stuff digitally the book ended
shots of the farm levels here really
show off what they've been able to do
because it all just kind of works I feel
so relieved that they finally delivered
the Bernard reveal I wasn't sure if they
were going to swap his role from the
book with Sims and I'm glad they didn't
his role turns out to be the same but
they presented him in a different way
and to that I say that they actually
made him a much better character in the
show in the books he's a abrasive
antagonistic and completely unlikable
from the start and you know that he's up
to no good like there's no question
about it of course getting Tim Robbins
to play the role doesn't hurt even if
his status might have led some non-book
readers to Guess that there was more
going on with this character especially
in a situation where it felt like
somebody was above Sims and I like the
way they're delivering this in that you
really don't know now if there's even
someone above him or so on and I think
it was always kind of up in the air
because Jewel started to trust him you
couldn't tell for sure and the way he
pulled the wool over her eyes makes him
a lot more compelling plus they managed
to efficiently Express why the people in
charge don't see anything wrong with
what they do the idea of doing it for
the good of The Silo the idea of the
sacrifices of the few so the many can
survive even though you don't agree with
what they do you can't understand how
people could resort to a little murder
here and there if they believed it was
for the greater good if they believed it
was essential for survival speaking of
pulling the wool and generally
interesting character work in service of
driving the theme Billings really is
becoming a great character in his own
right his lying about having the
syndrome is another example of trying to
control information because you think
you know better and I love how that's
completely antithetical to the image he
projects to everyone and besides that
one thing he does come off as a
character that has his heart in the
right place which makes it all rather
complicated we're getting close to the
end and it's really difficult to see how
Jules could turn the tables from where
she's at she does have the hard drive
but we mostly know what's on that thanks
to George and Allison it has been a
while so in case you forgot if you say
you want to go outside that's what you
get to do and I don't see a situation
where Bernard and Sims being the
witnesses to her saying it wouldn't be
enough based on what the show is
presented this is all quite a bit
different than the book at this point
but I will say after this week it does
feel like it's going to the exact same
place I thought there was a possibility
that they might swerve or switch things
up but that seems less likely to me now
one sequence I didn't talk about was the
final flashback where Jules is hurt
because no one attended her mother's
funeral this was interesting because of
the effect it had on her emotionally but
also how it highlights the stigma that's
attached to not keeping your head down
and following the rules that's pervasive
especially in a culture that's closed
like The Silo Jules calling them cowards
and then sending the rabbit away made me
think about the contrast of the time she
spent with George at that point she
seemed pretty comfortable she couldn't
understand why he would risk so much for
the relics now we know a little bit more
we know that there were seeds planted
there from an early age for her to go
looking for answers about what happened
to him and her leaving mechanical to
finish what she started with Holston
makes even more sense where is that
going to take her I guess now she's
gotten more than she bargained for and I
can't wait to see what happens next
there are two more episodes to go and
they did officially announce that the
show has been renewed for season two
which is good news and I think that is a
great place to leave things please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
thank you